he is out ladder how are you good rich
how are you surprised that Hanley's on
the bench today do you think he Hanley
hasn't been good that's for sure
I think it probably ultimately would go
to matchups I'm not terribly surprised
but if Nunez did what he did before he
got hurt it's a better line up what do
you think of the series as a whole
Red Sox Astros break it down for me Wow
listen III don't know how the postseason
proceeds and I know there's some premium
starting pitchers obviously wouldn't you
wouldn't know that based on wild card
games with the awful starts of each one
of them tonight rich could be the
marquee starting pitcher match up
throughout who knows you know let's see
what you know the Dodgers do and is
there going to be a Kershaw Scherzer
matchup or you know do we later on see
either of Erlander sale against Kluber
but today could be a real fun game to
watch a few loves pitching and I think
both of these guys are premium I think
the only thing that really I always look
for is ultimately who's feeling good
about what they've been doing who's
which of the pitchers and players going
into postseason when they know that
they've had it locked up or either
banged up nicked up or not feeling
confident based on what they've done and
with that Verlander has been nothing
short of amazing since the trade sale
has been real Jekyll and Hyde
I mean august-september has been you
know he's either been really good or
really bad
I know personnel I mean we were talking
in July around baseball not only was he
a slam dunk to win the siyeong but he
you know he's talking about MVP so it
just shows you with a couple months I do
love them both III think they're premium
ace kind of stuff guys and it comes down
to the same thing rich and I know you
didn't watch baseball closely which of
the pitchers make the least amount of
mistakes and we're watching night and
night I watch the last night's game and
you know guys throw 98 99 hundred miles
an hour guys are turning on hitting
homeruns line drives it's amazing what
major league hitters can do if they know
what's coming yeah and then sales never
done it before
you mean you forget that because of all
of his strikeouts and all of his
terrific seasons that he's racked up one
after another he's never been on the
hill in October before and we've seen
already the first two
was never done it before in Severino and
gray they did not equip themselves very
well so what about sale against this
line I've gives you some confidence that
he's going to be able to go deep into
this game now it's a good point and no
matter where you are in your baseball
life this is what you dream of certainly
with Chris Sale and what's going on were
with the White Sox he got a new lease on
life and it has showed but it's
different RIT's I can tell you having
experienced some World Series and some
postseason games you know that as much
as you want to pretend and the answers
or canned answers when you see these
press conferences it's just another game
I'm just going to go out and play my
game
when the game starts it's just another
game it's not and if you have that
ability to really eliminate those
exterior distractions and and all of the
hype and pump that goes with it it's
usually the guy that will do well hey
Chris nails got his hands full I know
he's done well against the Astros but
the Astros across the board are the best
offensive team in baseball I mean so
many different statistical categories
and they hit left-handers so the matchup
says Chris Sale I trust his stuff I mean
he's a high elevated fastball 95 96 plus
upstairs he still has that back foot
slider that berry slider he's starting
to sprinkle in more changeups but you
know III think he when he's on and he
does what he does well it'll it'll still
be a tough call for the Astro hitters
but I like the astral on Al Leiter of
the MLB Network again they've got Game
one of Red Sox Astra's at 4:00 Eastern
today and then the game 2 of the Yankees
Indians that starts tonight surprise
that Sonny gray is out there and and
also Bauer I mean this could easily be
CC Sabathia against Kluber which is
tomorrow night's matchup why do you
think this is the we Game one matchup
that favored by both managers here oh
well III get the Sonny gray thing III do
I think with CC left-handed batting
average against or lefties pose a little
bit more of a problem for the Cleveland
lineup CC has been throwing well I think
that Joe Girardi has managed his innings
and his pitch counts and all of that
stuff for a guy that's been around a
long time he's got that ball Keeney and
I think that they really maneuver when
he feels right he's been good I mean
CeCe's grown into truly
pitcher I'm not surprised about sunny
great yeah he's been inconsistent he's
had some some bad games down the stretch
but I mean this is why they traded for
him rich I mean he's he was supposed to
complement you know at the top end of
the rotation Tanaka
came up with a huge game in his last
start with what 15 strikeouts but I
think Sonny gray is capable I think the
bigger question mark is Trevor Bauer as
good as the year that he's had outside
of maybe a Kershaw you know a clue
outside of Kershaw and sale and he's
sprinkling in a couple other names
cluepers right there at the best pitcher
in the game and I want to make sure that
he's you know getting off to start I
listen we got a lot of statistics that
we that we run over but this is pretty
profound in game five series 71% of the
teams that win Game one move on to the
next round
so Game one is very important in
baseball it has been statistically and I
don't know if I want my best pitcher and
one of the best pitchers in the game
pitching game - that's know knock on on
Trevor it sounds like it is what Trevor
has his big curveball he's a
loosey-goosey guy he's coming at you
he's pitched well against the Yankees
I think Terry Francona has had he's got
great options I mean we didn't talk
about Carrasco as good as he's been so
you know the depth and the rotation and
bullpen of the Indians they're the most
complete team for me a couple of more
minutes without Leiter here in the Honda
inside a report from the MLB Network
right here on the Rich Eisen show
handicap the National League side of
things for me who do you think is gonna
make the World Series now that we know
the final four in the NL oh well my gut
tells me I want to pick the Dodgers
because I want to believe that they were
the team that was rollin to be the best
team in the history of baseball and then
they ran into August and you know lost
whatever they were about 20 lost 20 out
of 25
they have Kershaw who's you know
obviously a great player if you can get
the guys that were banged up to come
back they have you know arguably if not
the best closure in the game in kenley
jansen
but with that said as to why I also like
the Indians I think now let's see what
happens with Scherzer I haven't heard
the latest news I don't know if you have
either know what Strasburg had a hell of
a year
I'm ok with that for as much as I would
like for Scherzer to be pitching game
once
Berg's been every bit as good especially
down the stretch you know and then Gio
Gonzalez is back to when he was a couple
years ago so the top one two three for
me with the Nationals absolutely matches
up with the Indians and I think it still
goes with that I know the mixin imagine
I know that the bullpens are great as we
saw with the Yankees and some other
teams the Indians and Red Sox but give
me three good starters that I can trust
that I think I think should go to the
game I know before I let you go how what
were your thoughts watching Archie
Bradley split the gap and then just you
know steam into third base ripped that
helmet off and stare at every one of s1
and if they were entertained or not I
mean that was incredible Wow you know
and I think that was his reaction rich
it's like you know I don't know the kid
and I hear the interviews he sounds like
a nice guy but you know it was listen if
you're Addie back then was that not just
an awesome moment you have you have your
pitcher who does not doesn't hit
shouldn't hit and then ropes a huge
triple yeah to be really you know what I
mean it ended up being a you know they
needed a few more later on what a game -
I did not anticipate that from Zack
Greinke he's had a graph of a year well
I mean and Bradley now I do believe
matches you al in career triples if I'm
not mistaken you you belted one out best
we can tell a first inning two-run
triple just like Archie Bradley but in
the first inning way back in 2001 do you
remember that out yeah I do
I what he got for me here I did it all
for Brad Penny who was throwing hard
first of all full disclosure I was one
of the worst hitters that ever stood in
the major league batter's box I will
tell you that not admit to it I'm not
I'm not a good hitter but no hey you
know every every once in a while I get
lucky but I wrapped it and then I
realized rich oh my god I got a run and
I'm fat and I'm slow and I get to second
I see John Stearns is the third-base
coach he's waving me I'm like what let's
hit a triple but I think I think you and
everybody else listed it would have had
an inside-the-park home run because
Preston Wilson go for it it rolled all
the way to the wall at Shea Stadium and
yeah I got a triple so are you saying
stand up you didn't slide it uses no
stand up they end up triple from the guy
who had a piano on his back is it true
that you try to lay down a bunt
earlier in the at-bat Allen's at a true
story i I used to do that a lot
so actually in me at bat I I was
terrible I would do the little butcher
boys turn pretend like I was bunting and
then as the pitcher would go I would I
would whine back he'd load whatever and
then at the timing was about right
because I I couldn't get that whole like
stay back thing and throw your hands so
yeah I actually butcher Boyd a triple
off a Brad Penny through it like 100
miles an hour don't ever anybody let
anybody take that away from you no I
will not take care of our love child as
always you gotta enjoy the playoff games
on MLB Network tonight and tomorrow
again Game one of Astros Red Sox today
the Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on radio stations across the
country and audience if you like that
video be sure to download our app and
I'll be sure to help the NFL figure out
what it catches